[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce 78 actu
nous démarrons ce par ce mardi avec une
manifestation à l'appel du syndicat CGT
pour la sauvegarde des retraites des
syndicalistes retraité donc de la CGT se
sont rassemblés ce mardi à Versailles
pour dire leur mécontentement par
rapport à leur situation qui selon
Sagrave hausse de la TVA généralisée
accès aux soins de plus en plus
difficile autant de sujets que la
délégation ivinoise a pu aborder ce
mardi avec le préfet sur place yolen
Torz et Jonathan Vman ils viennent
d'être reçu par le préfet des retraité
évelinois de la CGT se sont rassemblé ce
matin à Versailles pour crier leur
mécontentement euh nous avons porté tout
le malvivre des retraités aujourd'hui
dans lesines mais aussi en France c'est
l'union confédérale des raité CGT qui a
lancé cette campagne au niveau national
parmi les nombreux sujets qui fâchent le
report de la revalorisation des pensions
de retraite au 1er octobre l'accès aux
soins de plus en plus difficile mais pas
seulement on estime que depuis 93 le
pouvoir d'achat des retraites a été
diminué de 20 %. donc partant de là on a
vécu aussi les franchises de santé
aujourd'hui on vit la la hausse de la
TVA on est taxé à 0,3 % pour la Casa
pour l'aide à l'autonomie ces retraités
en colère estiment aussi qu'il jouent un
rôle important au sein de la société
s'il n'existait pas s'ils arrêtent
aujourd'hui leur activité bénévole dans
la société il y a beaucoup de gens qui
seraient encore plus en difficulté les
associations et cetera donc on n'est pas
que des bouches à nourrir improductives
dans le département des iveline plus de
1500 cartes pétition ont déjà été
signées elles seront déposées à l'Élysée
ce jeudi 20 février par une délégation
représentant les h départements de
l'Île-de-France la semaine dernière le
Premier ministre Jean-Marc herro a
présenté les grandes lignes du projet de
loi d'orientation et de programmation
pour l'adaptation de la société au
vieillissement c'était le fruit d'une
concertation lancée en novembre dernier
alors l'accent a été mis sur le maintien
à domicile avec une augmentation des
plafonds d'aide et puis aussi un soutien
pour les aidants via une aide au répi
bonsoir à mes deux invités Isabelle
Archan et Anne directrice et directrice
adjointe du de géronandicap à
maniléamoau pour rappeler gérandicap
c'est un un groupement de plusieurs
dispositifs sociaux et médicaux sociaux
et alors vous vous êtes à fond j'ai
envie de dire dans le plan dans le plan
dépendance présenté par Jean-Marc herou
puisque'il y a une aide très forte qui
est qui est donnée aux aidans et au
maintien à domicile c'est aussi le
travail que fait de longue date Géron
handicap d'abord je voudrais un avis sur
ce plan dépendance je l'ai dit l'accent
est mis sur le maintien à domicile il y
a 650 millions d'euros qui vont être
mobilisés par par an est-ce que c'est un
plan qui est ambitieux pour vous
Isabelle rochan en tous les cas c'est un
plan qui reprend les différentes
conditions pour un une bonne qualité de
maintien au domicile puisque il reprend
des conditions au niveau de
l'accompagnement en aide humaine en aide
technique en aménagement des logements
et et l'accompagnement des des proches
aidents euh des familles et et des
entourages donc c'est un plan qui pour
le maintien domicile des personnes âgées
dépendantes une approche globale vous
vous le ressentez ça auprès des des
publics que vous recevez qui sont à la
fois des publics handicapés mais
également en perte de dépendance que ce
maintien à domicile est souhaité alors
le maintien au domicile est souvent
exprimé hein comme étant le le souhait
en tout cas et et le le le projet des
personnes qui sont en situation de
handicap alors lié à l'âge hein mais pas
seulement ça peut être lié à une
pathologie ou lié à un handicap donc
c'est effectivement des des des des
projets qui sont exprimés et pour lequel
la la société doit non seulement
apporter une place à la personne même si
elle est en perte d'autonomie je voyais
dans le reportage précédent pas
seulement des des des coûts en terme de
de de de dépenses que ça peut générer et
c'est aussi le projet qu' qu'on doit
accompagner pour l'ensemble de la
famille qui est impactée et pas
seulement la la personne qui le souhaite
mais aussiement parler l'ensemble de la
famille ces fameux aidants qu'il faut
aider alors pour le maintien domicile
l'idée donc c'est d'apporter un soutien
financier plus important par le Viet de
l'augmentation de de l'APPA laallcation
de personnal d'autonomie ça veut dire
que du coup les gens pourront faire
appel à des association d'aide à
domicile il y a PL tort d'association
d'aide à domicile c'est parfois
difficile de s'y retrouver et vous au
sein de handicap vous avez proposer vous
peut-être même les premis je sais pas à
proposer ça mais l'idée était plutôt
bonne de proposer des formations auprès
de justement des personnels qui
interviennent auprès des de ces
associations ça c'est important alors
oui c'est important c'est important au
niveau de la reconnaissance de ces
professionnels qui sont formés à
l'accompagnement des personnes âgées ou
en situation de handicap ou des
personnes malades c'est important pour
une bonne qualité de de maintien à
domicile également alors les premiers
peut-être pas au niveau de gér handicap
en général mais mais en tous les cas on
apporte une réponse pour les structures
d'aide à la personne yvelinoise vous en
avez beaucoup justement de de de ces
structures qui font appel à vous pour
former leur personnel alors il y a
beaucoup de structures il y a aussi
beaucoup de structures qui sont en
difficulté euh et pour lequel il est
quelquefois difficile d'assurer le
maintien au domicile alors que ce sont
les les les premières lignes hein de de
l'accompagnement et et qui permet le
maintien au domicile justement toute la
difficulté c'est de pouvoir avoir
suffisamment de de moyens humains aussi
enfin de ressources en tout cas pour
permettre aux personnes de partir en
formation donc on est en lien très très
très régulièrement avec toutes ces
structures euh qui nous font part aussi
de leur difficulté d'organiser la
formation mais mais mais je handicap a
très vite réfléchi sur le maintien au
domicile c'est possible grâce aux aides
humaines mais les aides humaines formé
et donc j'ai handicap a réfléchi à à
développer une offre de formation
adaptée pour l'acquisition de
connaissances mais aussi le
développement de compétences à la fois
relationnel et technique pour maintenir
le le le le domicile dans les meilleures
conditions possibles en tout cas en
proposant cet accompagnement de de
professionnel un point aussi je voudrais
avoir votre avis sur le le le le soutien
qui va donc apporté à ces fameux aidents
familiaux donc ça ça peut être un parent
un enfant enfin ou quelqu'un en tout cas
de de de proche il y a aussi une aide
financière qui va être apportée pour que
ces aidants puisse souffler un petit peu
vous au sein de handicap vous organisez
des rencontres aidans qui se passent non
pas dans une structure hospitalière et
non pas gandicap mais dans une brasserie
dans un café hein c'est c'est volontaire
parce que justement pour sortir un peu
du cadre un peu médical dans lequel
peuvent évoluer ces ces aidents qui qui
ont beaucoup de courage pour s'occuper
de leur de leur de leurs proches euh ça
fonctionne bien je CIS c'est mis en
place depuis une petite Ann depuis juin
depuis juin 2013 ça fonctionne bien
puisque ce sont des rencontres tous les
15 jours autour d'un thème avec un un
animateur des aidentss qui ont plaisir à
se retrouver des des participants qui
ont plaisir à se retrouver tous les 15
jours qui trouvent notamment un lieu de
une source d'information au sujet de
autour de sujets diverses mais aussi
beaucoup de convivialité de tien puisque
le partage et nous l'ONS confirmé encore
tout à l'heure le partage bah de
situation et de ce qu'ils vivent au
quotidien euh les soutiennent
mutuellement qu'est-ce qu'il vous dit
just une liberté de parole qui est
permise justement parce que c'est dans
le cadre dans un d'un café qui est
complètement intégré dans la vie qui
permet aussi aux personnes de pas se
retrouver dans un lieu confiné où il
serait question juste de leurs
difficultés c'est permettre un échange
assez assez facile aussi dans dans le
café donc c'était des rencontres qui qui
fonctionne bien ça fait partie d'un
programme plus vaste aussi qui met en
place d'autres
actions envers envers les aidents sous
la forme par exemple d'ateliers
thématiques qui peuvent être la
déclinaison d'un entré dans café entré
dans café c'est donc le nom de ces
rencontres dans dans le café euh on
prend pour exemple par exemple oui je le
disais donc un un entédans sur le thème
de
l'alimentation l'alimentation qui peut
du coup évoquer des problématiques
telles que je suis complè déborder je
n'ai plus l'occasion d'inviter des amis
à dîner comment je fais pour m'organiser
qu'est-ce que je peux proposer à la
personnes qui j'accompagne au
quotidienim de
vies voilà et après la thématique ça
peut être ben comment on peut adapter
des recettes très très simples comment
proposer des outils d'organisation et
comment partager après ce plaisir de et
la convivialité autour d'un repas je
voudrais vous faire réagir très
rapidement sur un dernier axe du plan
c'est l'adaptation des des loges et là
aussi je handicap intervient vous étiez
vous étiez vraiment novateur sur la
question oui le centre de ressources
d'information et de conseil en aide
technique qui est présent à G handicap
animé par une ergothérapeute
ergonome souhaite soutenir les aidants
professionnels familiaux et les
personnes directement concernées par la
perte d'autonomie en conseillant sur les
aides techniques possibles à mettre en
place et adapté à chaque situation en
formant les professionnels et les et les
familles à de ces aides techniques et
puis en allant jusqu'à
préconiser conseiller préconiser des
adaptations pour le logement ou même
pour les postes de travail puisque on
peut être en situation de handicap et et
toujours en situation d'emploi tout à
fait mais merci en tout cas vous deux
d'être venu sur le plateau de téfil On a
vu apparaître le bandeau de J handicap
si on veut avoir toutes les informations
sur tout ce que vous proposez et qui
sera qui est inclus dans ce projet de
plan dépendance du Premier ministre
Jean-Marc herud le plan projet qui sera
d'ailleurs présenté le 9 avril prochain
au Conseil des ministres pour une entrée
en vigueur en 2015 merci donc à vous
deux d'être venus en plateau réagir sur
ce plan allez on va poursuivre avec un
sujet consacré au patois alors
aujourd'hui même la ville de Saverne a
été la première ville de France à
adopter une la Charte européenne des
langues régionales ce qui signifie que
les habitants de la commune pourront
effectuer leur démarche en alsacien ce
qui nous fait dire qu'en France il y a
78 langues régionales et bien vous ne le
savez peut-être pas mais au 19e siècle
tous les habitants de notre département
ne parlaient pas ivelinois il existait
un patoi il se trouvait du côté de manth
la jolie Anthony rche a remonté la
piste il était un temps où certains
ivelinois parlaient une autre langue
au-delà des souvenirs il ne reste plus
que quelques rares document comme cette
monographie de
1898 à l'époque le ministre de
l'éducation nationale commande à ses
instituteurs des études communales en
vue de l'exposition universelle de Paris
entre la partie géographique et
historique
monsieur bhom maître d'école à
folinville petit village yvelinois de
776 âes semble étonné par le pas toi mon
toi apparemment les habitants déformment
en fait beaucoup de mots et là il
explique par exemple que la lettre A est
prononcée avec le son de la lettre O on
dit une pote une tble une rve et cetera
qui ressemble
beaucoup un vieux français en fait à une
façon ancienne de parler le français
avec des des des y à la place de ha avec
des accents plus aigus que graves au
milieu du 19e siècle la ville de
mantelajolie compte environ 3500
habitants le chemin de fer ne traverse
pas encore la commune mais le parlet
populaire y est bien installé au grand
désarrois du sous-préfet Armand Cassan
qui rédige un ouvrage consacré à la
ville en 1833 il porte un jugement assez
assez sévère sur sur ces particularités
locales qui qu'il décrit comme autant de
vice he c'est des expressions assez
fortes qu'il l'emploie d'expressions
corrompues encore des termes assez forts
il va même jusqu'à parler de de
barbarisme de l'ignorance depuis cet
autre temps ces intonations semblent
avoir disparu le beta est redevenu le
bétail l'ancov l'alcov le Manoi ne fera
donc pas partie des langues régionales
reconnues par la Charte européenne
charte que l'État doit encore
adopter allez une page culture et même
un retour en arrière le hip hop à 30 ans
sur 50 ans Eveline dans le cadre de la
3e saison des Pulsations Urbaines le
musée de la ville présente une nouvelle
exposition et donne surtout la parole au
street artiste aura de VC claire Cambier
et Lodi
moine blanc
be
1984 il y a 30 ans déjà la mythique
compagnie de danse hip- hop et Black
blomber faisaient leur premier pas à
5ant en yeline territoire qui fut l'un
des berceaux du genre en France célèbre
tout au long de l'année cet anniversaire
au travers de différents rendez-vous
parmi ceux à ne pas manquer notons que
le musée de la ville présente jusqu'au
28 juin une nouvelle exposition baptisée
street culture Sky elle s'intéresse
naturellement au Hipop mais plus
largement aux cultures urbaines skate
danse et Graf notamment cette culture là
est une culture importante sur le
territoire pas seulement à 50 ans
Yveline mais c'est une culture qui est
souvent pas assez reconnue et elle
mérite qu'on en parle mais c'est aussi
une culture qui a des valeurs vraiment
propres qui sont et revendiquer à la
fois de se débrouiller soi-même mais
aussi du respect de l'autre de la valeur
par la compétence et pas par par ce
qu'on est ou par la valeur sociale c'est
des choses qui sont très importantes
pour les hipopers et qu'on a voulu
traduire dans cette exposition une
rétrospective à travers laquelle le
musée donne la parole au street artistes
du territoire qui ont accepté de
témoigner de leur univers de création
chacun son idée en fait moi j'ai
travaillé surtout dans le groupe du
sket où on a partagé vidéo beaucoup de
clichés les les lieux où on aime bien se
retrouver qu'on appelle des spots et
après en fonction des autres contacts
ils ont apporté leur leur univers à eux
soit le monde du rap soit le monde du
Graf et pareil soit leur spot soit leur
façon de filmer objet texte vidéos et
objets d'époque ponctue la visite une
occasion de s'interroger sur l'évolution
de ces cultures je pense que c'est
quandême un petit peu plus accessible
pour tous il y a beaucoup qui en vivent
maintenant je pense ce soit du gra de la
danse ou ha mais de pouvoir
toucher à ce monde hum qui était un
petit peu à l'époque un peu
ghetto un petit peu un aspect un peu
négatif et je pense que maintenant ça a
complètement changé ça c'est beaucoup
ouvert il y a beaucoup de Battles qui
sont
organisés le sket on le voit partout il
y a un comb du sket le grap il y en a
qui sont devenus maintenant des artistes
très connus donc c'est vrai P a
largement évolué les codes
vestimentaires ont évolué aussi soit
dans les skates ou les danseurs
complètement changé pour s'inier à ces
pratiqu TR ateliers oir gra et glisse
animé par des professionnels seront
présentés de mars à
avril ce 7 lactu est terminé merci de
votre attention dans quelques instants
vous avez rendez-vous avec le magazine
municipal 2014 présenté par Wilfred
Richy bonne soirée à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous